it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we reveal the stories behind the
headlines and for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond let's start
with this new slate very exciting of
Barbie dolls hitting the market
well Laura Mattel is unveiling some new
Doles to represent everyone
we've continued to increase our
commitment to representation with a
variety of diverse dolls the addition of
the Barbie with Down Syndrome was
created to allow even more children to
find a doll that represents them
[Music]
Laura it's about time that Barbie
represented these precious people you
know they're often ignored I'm glad
Barbie's doing this and to Mark Asian
American and Pacific Islander month
they're now releasing a new anime Wong
doll I also think it's wonderful that
they're working on a doll to elevate
cognitive loss and Elderly Care
awareness oh that's nice and it's so
special that it even talks Laura oh the
best way to get something done if you if
you hold near and dear to you that you
like to be able to
anyway
you little what's he saying kids just
pull the string again and see if you can
figure it out imagine the hours of
family fun Laura you know Raymond at
Mass this morning there was a um a
father and a son with Down syndrome and
he was so precious and he was you know
singing and looking for the hymns
and he was such a beautiful boy and just
seeing him interact with his brother and
how and I think that's wonderful I'm
glad I'm really glad they did I agree no
I'm glad they're celebrating that and it
actually is something children need and
would be drawn to he doesn't have any
agenda or any sideline that appeals to a
dog and obviously our Biden doll there
was our own little deep fake but now
artificial intelligence generated images
are becoming the norm in political ads
the GOP just released this one with A.I
and Joe Biden and China overtaking
Taiwan now progressives are using AI to
literally drag their opponents a month
ago a new Instagram page surfaced called
Republicans already it has 246 000
followers and dozens of AI generated
images of Republican lawmakers dressed
in drag it's meant to really call out
the hypocrisy of the GOP
now Lord to be a hypocrite the person in
question would actually have to engage
in the thing they're decrying near as we
know none of these men actually
cross-dressed except on this guy's
computer oh look all of this is like
being thrown in the middle of Ready
Player one only we aren't ready for this
world that we're encountering and it's
very dangerous when you're talking about
elections something needs to be done
here I mean it's it's clearly not satire
he's clearly using it as a substantive
political attack
so at that point
um there's there's going to be a lot of
soul searching on this kind of stuff
well there's a democratic congresswoman
I agree with her she wants warnings on
these ads on any AI created image so
it's clear that this is a fake we're
going to need that in political ads
particularly late in a campaign season
and the Navy is apparently now going all
in Laura not only for representation but
drag queens once again in an effort to
boost recruitments they appointed Yeoman
second class Joshua Kelly as an official
digital Ambassador Anchors Away
I receive attention just for being
myself on a daily because being queer
being non-binary someone such as myself
on a regular gets stared at I'm at the
top of my game I wonder if there were
the big dogs girls come on leave the
second in the world to the men
he calls himself Harpy Daniels Laura the
Navy claims they employ Harpy to attract
a wide range of potential candidates who
exactly are these candidates I mean are
they going to stand on the deck of the
ship and out drag the Chinese what what
does combat look like in falsies and
heels and why drag queen why is
everything drag queens why not mimes or
Goths or clowns I mean there are a
thousand different groups of performers
that the Navy and everybody else could
reach out to I I don't understand this
kind of binary tract if you will well I
think you know my question is what would
Admiral Nimitz or Admiral Charles Hughes
think of what's happened to the United
States of America that's that's what I
wonder those great men and everything
they sacrifice all right Raymond
um thank you and Raymond is by the way
in Tennessee right now he spoke to
Nashville's natives about how the police
are suppressing the Covenant Shooters
Manifesto in a lot more plus he's gonna
be signing his new Edison book at Cool
Springs Barnes Noble this Saturday at 11
I am hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else